ces voix là c'est vraiment moi aussi
c'était les vendredis à 20h à la sortie
du dernier clip de pnl au dd on regarde
un extrait c'est complète alors ces
nouveaux clients on a un extrait vous
montrer il a été vu je crois combien
fait 15 morts en trois jours
je kiffe franchement bravo et le titre
et où fin vraiment et moi ce que je sais
qu'ils n'ont jamais fini interviews et
non et ils ont raison continuer ces
décharges faire du marketing par deux
teasers avant de dévoiler la vidéo je
fasse un détail la paix kulhavy certains
regrettent tomber
ce genre de chez toi je reprends ta
voiture mal garée puis je retire ton pv
je recherche un billet d affaires des
plans dans la planque un peu trop peiné
jean un bisou à meeke a faim dans la
cave +6 l'affectons rogen et les
bas-côtés ma part ce que les yankees ne
tomberont jamais son messagerie un
poteau démarre dans la jungle messieurs
en qualifs et déception s'est demandé si
les images du clip était vraie ou fausse
alors certaines séquences sont vraies je
vous montrais comme celle ci regardez
voilà celle ci est vrai voilà ça c'est
vrai bon déroulement et là d'autres
séquences où étaient au travail en post
prod c'est le cas de cette séquence
regardez c'est là que la famille pearson
nous inquiète jusqu'au dernier grand
toujours demande un peu parce que je
suis président
à
son patrimoine beaucoup mieux cohabiter
surtout hautement très très fort bravo
apple est l'exact le numéro un où est ma
chérie je me sens trop fort trop fort
parce que moi je jure à partir de minuit
ça a commencé à être mis en fait je
regardais giulani genre je me réveille
et on va regarder
il avait juste un petit truc et il ya
des francophones qui ont créé des
groupes watts à se réunir et s'informer
de ce qui s'est passé en vous